[Music]
on this saturday night demanding justice
for the victims of flight 752
the two-year anniversary of iran
shooting down a passenger plane my wife
my only child along with 174 other
innocent human beings and an unborn
child were murdered in cold blood the
fury and frustration with tehran and
ottawa when covid19 makes your holiday a
giant headache if i could go back and
tell my old self this i would have 100
cancel the complications in foreign
destinations once you test positive plus
the golden globes minus the glitz and
glamour you can't just walk a red carpet
and act like that's your contribution to
society what's fueling a backlash and a
boycott
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight on a somber note
memorials are taking place in canada and
around the world marking a tragic
anniversary two years ago ukraine
international airlines flight 752 was
shot down over iran 55 canadian citizens
were among the 176
victims today prime minister justin
trudeau joined their family members for
an online vigil and as david aiken
reports there are new efforts to force
iran to provide compensation
we are the mothers of
innocent passengers
on flight ps
752
let us remember
their names
176 perished after two iranian
surface-to-air missiles struck ukraine
airlines international flight ps752
in the early morning hours of january
the 8th 2020.
two years later some families are still
angry
my wife my only child along with 174
other innocent human beings and an
unborn child were murdered in cold blood
angry not just at iran but frustrated as
well with canadian authorities canada
must stand for justice and it is time
for us all to stand on the right side of
the history today now and with urgency
some families along with the opposition
conservatives want the trudeau
government to do more to punish the
regime in iran during saturday's visual
prime minister justin trudeau responded
let me say this directly
i promise you
we will always continue fighting for the
accountability
so far canada has acted with other
nations whose citizens perished on
flight
ps752 a multilateral approach taken in
part because canada has not had formal
diplomatic relations with iran since
2012 so it has acted in concert with
sweden the united kingdom and ukraine as
part of the international coordination
and response group to force iran to
accept its responsibilities and
compensate all victims
but this week that group said iran has
refused to pay compensation and further
negotiations were quote futile ron
though said it is ready to pay a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars to each
family but only if it can negotiate
those arrangements bilaterally or
one-on-one that's an approach canada and
its allies have rejected canada will
stand together with the members of the
coordination group as a united front and
we will not rest
until iran
is held accountable canada and its
allies now plan to turn to international
law to force iran to take responsibility
david aiken global news ottawa
from diplomatic boycotts of next month's
winter olympics to fears about democracy
and security being threatened multiple
countries are taking a stand against the
chinese government and pressure is
mounting on ottawa to devise a way to
deal with beijing our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson spoke with
canada's new foreign affairs minister
about this mercedes what did melanie
jolie have to say
nithu the signs are there that canada is
finally working on a china strategy
the government has taken a tougher tone
on china since the two michaels came
home in september
just two weeks ago on the west block
prime minister justin trudeau made
international headlines when he accused
china of coercive diplomacy and using
commercial interests to play western
nations off each other
we need to do a better job of working
together and standing strong so that
china can't you know play the angles and
divide us one against the other beijing
responded by stating that canada-china
relations are quote at a crossroads and
telling canada the country has a choice
to be a partner or a rival
this week on the west block we sit down
with foreign affairs minister melanie
jolie for her reaction jolie says the
prime minister has tasked her with a top
priority of coming up with that china
strategy
we need to have that strategy we need to
make sure that
we presented to canadians that's part of
my mandate letter from
the prime minister and that's exactly
what i'll be doing uh in the coming
weeks and months and i look forward to
answering your question with more
details
because it is a fundamental foreign
policy question
what that strategy will look like
remains a question jolie would not say
if canada will ban huawei's 5g network
as other five eyes countries have done
on china's demands for canada to get on
board as an ally jolie called the
relationship complex and said canada
will continue to call out china on human
rights issues but leave the door open to
talking well see
what i think as a foreign foreign
minister is we need to be able to talk
to everybody and even with when we
disagree with them and we've disagreed
with china on many issues uh inclu
including the arbitrary detention of
both michaels
at the same time uh we know that there's
our economic ties that our businesses
have
with china and so it is a complex
relationship and canadians expect us to
navigate it strategically prime minister
justin trudeau has called for a united
front of western countries to deal with
china's growing influence and for those
western countries to work together but
so far what that looks like in practical
terms remains unclear
we'll have more of that on the west
block tomorrow nithu mercedes stephenson
in ottawa thanks mercedes
to the pandemic now ontario is adding
additional covid19 vaccine clinics to
accelerate booster doses for education
and child care workers there are a
record number of people in ontario
hospitals nearly 2 600 as of today
385 people are in intensive care today
quebec saw a sharp increase in deaths
due to the virus 44 more people lost
their lives the highest number since
last january
it is a similar situation south of the
border confirmed covid19 cases and
hospitalizations are skyrocketing across
much of the u.s in california the number
of people in hospital with kovid has
more than doubled in just two weeks and
as jennifer johnson explains the burden
being placed on health care workers is
difficult to bear
one in four u.s hospitals are now
reporting critical staff shortages as
coven 19 patients fill up rooms this
missouri hospital is out of nurses
housekeepers and beds every place is
full and we're back where we started
where everybody's looking all over the
country for beds from small towns in
missouri to big cities the story is the
same
luminous community medical center just
outside washington dc has seen a 925
percent increase in covet 19 cases since
thanksgiving that's what hurts the most
because the erosion of these care teams
is invariably going to lead to an
erosion of health care quality
more than 120 000 americans are
currently hospitalized with covet 19 the
highest level in a year on friday close
to 1800 died from the virus the phone
calls to their families are the hardest
part for those on the front lines i'm so
sorry to be calling you like this i'm
sorry
i'm sorry for what you're going through
more than 70 percent of those
hospitalized with the virus are
unvaccinated including 63 year old ned
epperson if i had to do it all over
again i wouldn't think twice
take the shot just 62 percent of
americans are fully vaccinated the cdc
is urging unvaccinated adults to get
protected as many are infecting children
under the age of five pediatric
hospitalizations are at their highest
level since the pandemic began parents
are feeling the strain we might even
just keep our 13 year old out of class
and our four-year-old out of the
preschool
most likely next week because it's just
not worth taking a chance essential
workers are being hard hit too about 20
percent of new york city police officers
are out sick with covet 19 more than 1
000 police officers firefighters and
paramedics in los angeles too those
whose jobs are to protect are unable to
protect themselves from this quick
spreading virus
jennifer johnson global news washington
in the uk government advisors say a
fourth dose of a covid19 vaccine is not
needed for nursing home residents and
those over 80. health officials say a
third shot is offering lasting
protection against serious illness data
shows protection against hospitalization
remains at about 90 percent three months
after that booster for people over 65
the government is being advised to focus
on getting more third doses into arms
pandemic protocols are keeping a lot of
canadians at home this weekend and so is
the frigid weather most of the extreme
colder snowfall warnings affect parts of
alberta saskatchewan manitoba and yukon
some regions in bc are facing the same
but the province's south coast where
it's slightly warmer is being warned
about snow and freezing rain and parts
of newfoundland and labrador are being
alerted to strong winds or blizzard
conditions
as they were arching and yes don't stand
underneath those things it'll kill you
in bc more snow is accumulating today
after some people were dodging falling
ice chunks on friday a dangerous mix of
snow wind and freezing rain hitting the
province's south coast and up north
bitter cold temperatures dropping to
minus 40. in metro vancouver a king tide
causing significant damage to the
popular sea wall prompting waterfront
closures as municipal crews grapple with
the flooding and debris
people in new brunswick have started
digging out after the first major winter
blast of the season bringing 35
centimeters of snow to areas like st
john slick and near white out conditions
prompting the closure of several
highways across the province for hours
and wind gusts of up to 100 kilometers
per hour leaving thousands without power
in pakistan cold winter weather turned
deadly at a popular mountain resort
northeast of islamabad 22 people died
when temperatures dropped to -8 degrees
celsius overnight police say most of the
victims died of hypothermia in their
cars heavy snowfall attracted thousands
of tourists to the mountain town many
ended up getting stranded because of the
winter storm and clogged roads
after days of deadly protests fueled by
soaring gas prices there is peace in
kazakhstan tonight troops are out
patrolling the streets as people lined
up to try to buy food and fuel yesterday
kazakhstan's president ordered the
military to shoot and kill protesters
now the country's former security chief
has been arrested accused of trying to
overthrow the government kareem massimov
used to head up the country's
counter-intelligence and anti-terror
agency until the president fired him on
wednesday massimov also twice served as
the country's prime minister a warning
now about our next story disturbing
video has emerged from brazil where a
giant boulder fell on some boaters
[Applause]
the slab of rock broke off of a cliff
crashing down on a lake killing at least
six people up to 20 are still missing
dozens more were injured and most of
them have been released from hospital
recent torrential rains may be to blame
coming up a tax paid after you sell your
home could it be the solution to soaring
house prices
housing prices in canada's most
notorious real estate markets just keep
hitting the roof in toronto the average
home price is now more than 1.1 million
dollars that's up almost 22 percent from
a year ago head west to vancouver and
you'll have to shell out even more 1.2
million that's nearly 12 percent higher
than last year
now the think tank generation squeeze
believes it has a solution to stop bc's
soaring prices a new tax could it work
ted tarnecki finds out
there's now
2.44 trillion dollars worth of real
estate in bc up 22 percent from a year
ago a new study suggests we're long
overdue and taking bold action to stop
this price climb with among other things
a new surtax and no it is not a panacea
for the problem right now because we
have allowed the contagion of
unaffordability to grow so much and
spread so far that we can't solve this
problem tomorrow
but we have to take the steps to at
least begin
committing to stall home prices the
study suggests homes worth more than a
million and that's 10 percent canada
wide should pay half of one percent tax
it means the owner of a 1.2 million
dollar home would pay 400 a year to be
paid when the home was sold so after 10
years the new tax would be at least four
thousand dollars depending on any
further increases in value a 1.5 million
dollar home would cost a thousand a year
or 10 000 after 10 this to help stall
prices no this would just make housing
more expensive and more scarce this
would do the opposite for housing
affordability if you want to lower the
cost of something make more of it the
study suggests most canadians owning
expensive property are unknowingly part
of the problem i'm in that boat i just
got told by bc assessment that my home
went from 1.7 to 2.2 million dollars
over the past year
i got a half million dollars of wealth
well i slept
it was 35 years ago when then premier
bill van der zam's government introduced
the property transfer tax to help slow
home price increases at the time the
average price in vancouver was 150 000
it didn't work but the tax it's still
there collecting 1.5 to 2 billion
dollars a year and now the tax man might
cometh again the feds are also seriously
considering a home equity tax
and that could be in the form of what
happens in the states it could be just a
straight-up capital gains tax that we
see on the sale of secondary homes here
in canada or it could be this version of
a surtax ted chernake global news
vancouver
an important food recall to tell you
about tonight eight varieties of dole
salads and five from president's choice
are being recalled because of possible
listeria contamination they were sold at
stores across the country and have best
before dates of january 8th or 9th the
salads should be thrown out or returned
to the place of purchase listeria can
cause vomiting fever and in rare cases
even death
the coronavirus and vacation nightmares
ahead when testing positive tests your
patients
testing positive for covet 19 while
abroad is the total opposite of a
vacation as ann gaviola reports the
highly contagious omicron variant is
creating a whole new hassle for sun
seekers
in early december cindy norton arranged
a 15-person trip to cuba in honor of her
mother who passed away in the spring we
decided to take a family trip among some
a lot of family friends obviously
and just scattered some smashes on the
beach the memorial trip took a turn when
her partner tested positive for kovid
days before their scheduled flight back
to canada he's feeling fine he's been
fishing all week and having a ball
and now all of a sudden he's got covet
so we're kind of freaking out a little
bit he was made to quarantine at another
hotel and had to book a new flight home
two days later cindy's experience is
similar to amy's she was also in augie
and cuba but at a different resort a
couple of weeks later she was forced to
go to a quarantine hotel alone after she
tested positive for covid though her
boyfriend did not it was extremely scary
when they first got me she says drinking
water was limited there was no hot water
and the food was not appetizing in
addition to the added stress and turmoil
she says she paid more than 600 for four
extra nights stay a pcr test and other
costs and it's not clear if she'll be
reimbursed in an effort to warn people
about the risks amy has taken to
facebook and tick tock if i could go
back and tell my old self this and just
give myself a glimpse of what i was
going into i would have 100 cancel it
was not worth the stress she recommends
traveling with your own covid test if
only for your own peace of mind
horror stories from travelers in cuba
mexico jamaica and other sunny
destinations being stranded after
positive covet tests abound on travel
sites and facebook groups
air canada this week suspended some
flights to sun destinations from january
24th until the end of april in light of
the current pandemic context this
industry expert recommends researching
exactly what happens if you test
positive while abroad and having a
contingency plan every jurisdiction
resort or cruise has its own rules i
think the worst thing is when things
take you by surprise that's when it gets
uncomfortable the omicron surge has
changed the risk calculation for people
traveling to another country and the
canadian government continues to advise
against non-essential travel ann gaviola
global news toronto
no stars no red carpet and no broadcast
next the controversy forcing the golden
globes to scale back
the start of a new year means the start
of another awards season in hollywood
and the popular ceremony that usually
kicks things off won't be the
star-studded event it normally is in
fact the golden globe awards won't even
be televised mike trolley explains
the hollywood foreign press association
is made up of around 90 international no
black journalists the joke highlighted
an important truth the golden globes
long seen as the unpredictable and
irreverent awards show was called out
for not having a single black voter in
protest of the lack of diversity tom
cruise for one returned his awards and
hollywood essentially put the golden
globes on notice change or else for a
long time celebrity culture
has literally just been about red
carpets and increasing your star power
yada yada
the last two years we've kind of been i
think somehow
in a way saying to our celebrities
you got to do something with your
power you can't just
walk a red carpet
and act like that's your contribution to
society nearly a year later hollywood
clearly hasn't forgotten best
performance by an actor in a television
series drama rapper snoop dogg announced
the nominations but when the golden
globes tried to line up celebrities for
the awards show no one rsvp'd not that
it mattered nbc pulled the plug on
televising this year's ceremony to give
the globes more time to enact meaningful
change
and to some extent it did make changes
creating a partnership with a leading
civil rights group and adding 21 diverse
voters
of those six are black short of the 13
it had pledged to add progress to be
sure but hollywood has seen it all
before i wanted to be here
to look out into this audience
and witness this moment of change in
recent years there has been an effort to
project a more balanced society on
screen and in the nominations but many
see those changes as wallpaper while the
foundation remains the same people are
just at a boiling point where they're
like i've had enough we don't care for
this anymore because it's the same
result you're saying one thing and doing
another thing right people want you to
act on integrity you know do what you
say if you're for diversity then make
sure you're for diversity right the
hollywood foreign press's first attempt
to change flopped maybe they can get the
sequel right
mike drolite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is conception based south in
newfoundland and labrador there are
beautiful spots all over canada please
keep sending us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]